my next super simple pan-fried recipe is
chicken and chicory and Masala sauce
[Music]
chicken breasts
add to hot olive oil
skin side down lay away from you to stop
it all splashing
[Music]
sliced chicory this versatile vegetable
can be read all white has a lovely
bitter taste and is great cooked all Raw
crush a clove of garlic and add then
sprigs of thyme
thank you
when the chicken skin is crisp turn over
along with a chicory
for the sauce add Masala a sweet
fortified wine from Sicily
then 150 ml of chicken stock
[Music]
to make the sauce Wonder too rich and
glossy add butter and thinner for 10
minutes
[Music]
plate up and spoon over the sauce
cooked in under 20 minutes chicken and
chicory in Masala sauce
[Music]
jerk chicken
I start by making the intense jerk
marinade first Scotch bonnet chilies
they may be small for packed real heat
and a fruity punch
then chop garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves cinnamon
nutmeg
and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
add olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
Brown the marinated chicken for 10
minutes
then add Worcestershire sauce
[Music]
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
foreign
spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking Good
my next super simple dish that just gets
better and better with time is chili
chicken with ginger and coriander
[Music]
start by chopping chicken thighs into
pieces
now on with the marinade
chopped garlic ginger red chili
and lemon juice
[Music]
in a pan toast coriander and cumin seeds
to release their flavors grind and add
to the chicken
then pour over plain yogurt add turmeric
and seasoning
mix and leave to marinade from two hours
to overnight
next fry chopped onions in olive oil
then add chopped garlic and ginger
ground coriander garam masala
and turmeric
tomato puree and butter
next add the marinated chicken and all
the remaining marinade and cook until
tender
finally top with coriander marinated for
flavor and cooked in 20 minutes chili
chicken with ginger and coriander a
simple stress-free wander
chicken stir fry with rice noodles first
off we're going to soak our noodles and
just pour the hot water over the rice
noodles 12 to 15 minutes to soften up if
you've got to Wok perfect if not just a
normal sized frying pan with big sloping
sides pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off take your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half we call this
butterfly in the chicken take a rolling
pin and nice and gently roll over the
chicken slice it in half start slicing
next wash your knife and finely slice
garlic
thin of the garlic
crispier this is a young
tender broccoli just slice them down
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized touch
of olive oil get a pan really nice and
ready
just starting to smoke drop the chicken
in first
just salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
broccoli in
feel strange putting raw broccoli in
like that normally
with Blanchard and boiling water dry it
out but you want that crunch
now soy sauce
that's exactly what I want now take that
out
give your pan and it'll wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
what really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing this quick stir fry very
classic two eggs in
whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it
at the side of the pan
like you season the eggs noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
and give that
a really nice mix
I want the egg to sort of almost bring
the dish together
the eggs cooked
[Music]
foreign
distribution of
chicken broccoli
garlic
lovely
I'm gonna just finish that that fresh
lime and there you have a very simple
delicious stir fry with rice noodles
[Music]